today i'd like to revisit some really
big numbers we've covered recently on
numberphile
and then maybe reflect on how big they
really are
now it all starts with this video we
made about the sum of three cubes
and this is a sort of area of research
that i'm i'm
actively engaged with tim browning told
us how all numbers could be expressed as
the sum of three cubes for example
ten can be represented as two cubed
plus one cubed plus one cubed there you
go the sum of three cubed numbers
eleven can be three
minus two and minus two
that's right you can use negative
numbers as well seventeen is as simple
as 2
2 and 1 while 45 can be
4 minus 3 and 2.
now look i've already told a little fib
here because
not all integers can be expressed as the
sum of three cubes in fact it's been
proven that numbers of these forms
can't be meaning these integers will
never work you'll never get them as the
sum of three cubes
sorry about that but all these other
ones should have a solution
i say should but here's a problem at the
time we made the video
there were three numbers below 100 that
should have been possible
that hadn't been found 33 42 and 74.
a number five viewer sander hussman let
a powerful computer loose on the problem
and he cracked 74. look at this three
absolute telephone numbers but that
still left
33 and 42. andrew booker from the
university of bristol refined the
algorithms
and used this supercomputer to solve 33.
here's what he found some real whoppers
again
that left 42 but with some extra help
you can guess what happened
here it is 42 cracked as well
still no rigorous proof the old numbers
are possible
that glorious moment still awaits
mathematics but at least those three
glaring
elephants in the room below 100 were
removed
but here's something else i didn't tell
you not only do mathematicians think
all integers are possible they think
they're possible
in an infinite number of ways take ten
for example i've already showed you
two one and one but there's also
four minus three and minus three
and these ones as well and as i said in
all likelihood
the options continue forever so this
solution for 42
that just happens to be the first one
among the number line
let the computers search for long enough
and they'll find another
and another and another and that's going
to bring us to number three because you
see
the number three is a bit of a pin-up in
this area of research
since mathematicians first started
dealing with this problem
it's been used to exemplify the whole
conundrum
now i'm sure you can think of this one
very obvious solution
one one and one and the next solution
isn't too tricky either
minus five four and four
but if this whole infinite solution
thing is true where's the next one
it was so hard to find this famous paper
on the topic noted
it was very difficult indeed classic
understatement
so andrew here decided the third
solution for three
that was his new holy grail again they
unleashed the computers
and you can guess what's coming here it
is everyone the next
solution for three now let's just focus
on that first number the positive one
it's got 21 digits just how big
is that cube i think we can easily take
a number like this for granted now
you've been seeing me make some of these
numbers as cubes here
with wooden blocks if i had more of them
like
a lot more of them what if i was to make
that big number that i just showed you
for the number three
i'm gonna need a lot more of them
would this new cube stretch into space
well yes would it reach the moon
or even the sun certainly
would it reach the nearest star that's
some 4.2 light years away
it would in fact here's a visualization
of the milky way
our massive sun our big star at the
center of the solar system
well in this context it's just a pretty
boring old speck of a star sitting here
amongst over a hundred billion others
you can't even really distinguish it
but if we built that epic cube and
started it here in my office
this is what it would look like it'd
dominate
the galaxy it'd be clearly visible from
a neighbor like andromeda
by the way it would also weigh more than
all the other atoms in the observable
universe
but that's another story and that number
it forms just
part of the third solution for the
number three
and remember in all likelihood there are
an infinite number of solutions
that are infinitely bigger think how big
these numbers must get
we often marvel at the size
the epicness of space of the universe
but look at the epicness here in numbers
and mathematics
this was just a basic math problem
something as simple as the sum of three
cubes
and it's blown our minds
if you'd like to see more mega favorite
numbers from people here on youtube
i'm going to put a link on the screen
and down in the description to a whole
bunch of things we've been doing and
maybe you can get involved too
and i'll also include links to all the
videos we've made
about the sum of three cubes
you